New York City backing down here did or
were necessarily win or did they more
likely call a truce well I think they
could call it a victory I mean this has
been a really big push that they've made
over these last few weeks they spent
many millions of dollars to to get this
legislation scuttled the legislation
being a cap on the number of cars Luber
can have in the city the the City
Council is quick to say that has been
tabled it's not off the table entirely
so if R doesn't uphold its end of the
bargain here as part of this deal we
could see a cap in the future Jack you
have a history with the taxi drivers
Association you told us that you want to
help them is this the right way hey
Scott hey Mark great to be with you here
from from Silicon Valley this is a
really interesting story you know first
of all we do want to know by the way in
that island of the Maldives does uber
exist first before anyone buys that
Island need to check that out whether
uber has a service there but moving on
to this story this is we're seeing Ober
fight this on multiple fronts you look
at France you look at other countries in
Asia South Korea a big issue there for
uber and back here on the home front
multiple cities having issues but for
the taxi in the street I want to see the
taxi industry thrive but it's not the
way the way to success is not by suing
or legal action the music industry is a
great case study of what not to do
suing university students when
downloading stuff from Napster was not
the way to success for the music
industry and the same thing here if the
tax industry the yellow cab if you want
survive and thrive they need now counter
with their own technology
- right calm for example is a piece of
software taxis can use to make their own
who bur that's how they should be
fighting this not in the court of law or
not in the legislative realm right well
that does sound like there's gonna be
some upfront investment there as well
look when it comes down to it jack
people are not over agnostic they're
either pro or anti uber how does or what
does uber do to turn perhaps some
government officials into Pro uber fans
well the fact is the customer has voted
over great service it's a service loved
by millions of people it makes their
lives easier they're using it in all
waise and who was gonna not only offer
more dispatch in terms of moving people
around it's now getting into brush which
has lose packages around uber groceries
and so on so this is a company on the
growth plan again my suggestion to folks
either in legislators or in terms of tax
is to think about business models that
can offer equal or better services so
it's all about end of the day the user
experience and the customer service the
feedback loop that you see an uber when
you can give a rating to that driver
that is critical in improving that
service we need the same now for the
yellow cab industry jackets David girl
reporter here in New York and I'm just
curious you know you mentioned that the
taxi industry could use some reform
could adopt some of this technology to
what extent do you think the horse is
out of the barn you have uber with such
widespread really dramatic growth here
in the city can taxis catch up right now
you know there's gonna be opportunities
for print kinds of services so for
example right now where doesn't have any
pre reservation so it's all on demand
you can imagine some fleets decide they
want to jump the gun and get ahead two
reservations you can have some
reservation type of customers customers
do want that and uber doesn't offer that
right now you can have services focused
on moving kids around in a very very
safe way that could be enough service so
the fleet guys have to start thinking
creatively about opportunities while
uber is very successful and it's great
to see the success of an American
startup now going global it's also the
still opportunities out there as you
look at the total opportunity of moving
people around a jack of when David did
his report earlier a last hour he was
telling us about it it seemed like a
political ad they had David Plouffe come
in and they had some of these uber
drivers on TV during the commercials
saying in a sense mayor de Blasio don't
take food off of my table don't penalize
my family what did you think of that
strategy
you know uber is a very aggressive
company a company that knows what it's
doing it's hired some great talent David
Plouffe being one of them
so they're really smart and what they're
doing but again the big picture is this
we know the case studies we know what
happened to the music industry we know
what happened to the book industry we've
seen this movie before this is not the
first time that we're looking at these
kind of clashes between incumbents and
the disruptors yeah and the fact is if
you want to win as the incumbent and
come back and fight you've got to do it
with the customer mind and with your own
technology fighting in the court of law
and fighting all three of these
political cases this is not the way it's
gonna it's gonna go down wealthier so
that's really where we need to go and
the big picture is there is a big
opportunity set across America now for
more companies to come in more startups
to come even as big as uber is you're
gonna see more innovation because the
fact is people no longer want to drive
themselves they want the convenience of
mobility on demand